[Music]
pet sales are soaring as
people stay home during the coronavirus
pandemic
[Music]
and turning to man's best friend is one
way of coping with chronic loneliness
[Music]
i think i made a good choice the dog
kept me busy i walked him a lot
i think he also loved the attention when
i was at home so much
after
[Music]
studies show the physical contact is
helping people cope with the crisis
but just how effective is it when your
liaison can't talk back
well it's the same case with a sex doll
business is booming
plus the technology has advanced you
still can't have a conversation with
these next robotic sex aides
but people do take them on road trips as
you'll see in a moment
a little warning some of the sounds in
this report may
get your pulse racing
now that she's got a head say hello to
lucy
for five years she's been learning to
speak
but her circuits still require a bit of
tinkering
um because it can't connect to the
network
it feels very upset lucy will one day be
able to hold
simple conversations because these dolls
are meant to offer more than just sex
we think about this as a human
we don't want to
let her talk something that will
make human upset so we'll try to make
him talk
something positive i love you or
you are the best or something like this
[Music]
for now leonard lou's dolls are limited
to little more than a moan
making them good enough for their
primary purpose
and the microchips in their heads mean
they can groan in
english japanese and chinese apparently
a good market for the dolls is germany
but leonard says their lack of german
hasn't proven a problem so far
when i see reviews from customers
when they get their doors they're very
happy
they try to share with with their
friends oh i got a nice store from
ireland tech
oh i feel so happy oh my life changed
with with julia with sayaka
coming into my life so when i see this
feedback emails or feedback reviews on
the internet
i feel honored and i am more
more prepared for the further movements
in this business like many sex doll
factories
demand for the products here has doubled
during the coronavirus pandemic
leonard liu has received countless
photos from happy customers
after all dolls are exempt from rules
around face coverings
and you can take them anywhere with you
regardless of physical distancing rules
during lockdowns they help their owners
forget how alone they actually are
leonard liu thinks he's doing a service
to humanity
i say mom i'm creating doors for men
and they do have requests they have
needs
and it have it has
big market and and my mother said
okay when you help others you can do
that
since it is not illegal
you can do that if you can help others
and with his vast array of fabricated
friends
he could help just about anyone
and let's bring in psychiatrist steven
john banerjee of india's national
institute of mental health and
neurosciences
first of all is a sex doll an effective
treatment for
chronic loneliness
yeah i see the it's it's very
individualized so it might be for some
it might
not be for some other it depends on the
need for social touch
as you were mentioning the need for
physical proximity
which has decreased during the lockdown
times
so uh it's it's one of the ways of
looking at it but then again
it depends it depends on society's
cultures about its acceptability
and whether it can really be a
replacement for a human touch
or human proximity what about pets then
pets have actually been studied you know
of over the last
six months there's been a lot of studies
especially with cats
uh dogs fish
and and they have classically been seen
to improve
the human connection it seemed to
relieve depression
anxiety loneliness and especially when
you're not able to meet others
they help you to stay connected the
feeling of human
the feeling of being a human uh is
retained
so they are pretty useful measures and
have been studied quite much in detail
so how else would you advise someone
who's feeling lonely and
forced into isolation
i think virtual medium have really taken
up
uh we are speaking virtually here and
uh staying connected to at least four or
five
key persons uh is the major key one
thing that we keep telling people who
are isolated or are in quantity
that make sure that at least you talk to
one person
uh be the stranger or known person per
day
and uh whatever hobbies you have
i think the lockdown and the covet
situation have given us
plenty of opportunities to nurture that
and
that's a real real way to stay positive
so so tech's been given a boost but a
british survey shows one in 10 people
experienced
loneliness before the great lockdown two
weeks in that rose
to one in four and young people were
three times more likely to feel those
feelings
why is that i mean i thought young
people spent most of their time
in front of their mobile phones
yeah i think as you rightly said
corbett has brought to us the real
difference between a digital interface
connectivity
and human connectivity we have been
doing some work on the concept of touch
hunger like we feel hungry for food
uh thirsty for water we also have a
touch hunger that can become chronic and
especially in this unprecedented
situations when we are not able to
physically meet people no matter how
much virtual it is
and that affects especially people who
are in you know the adolescents who are
young
because uh human touch social touch
affectionate touch are very important in
stages of human development and mostly
they will be affecting
the young and also the older people
especially those who are above 55 16.
i i like the quote
i i just wanted to point out a quote you
used in one of your papers you you said
all of humanity's problems stem from
our inability to sit in a room alone
what's wrong with us
yeah i i think that's a something which
really made me reflect
when i wrote the code that you're
mentioning from my paper on social
isolation and loneliness
uh i also have mentioned that we need to
convert the loneliness into solitude
which is uh you know the gray lines are
quite subtle
so i i believe that uh this break some
part of this break was needed
and uh it's it's a critical balance
between knowing how to stay
or spend time with oneself versus
socializing
and if either of it is not enough then
that's the problem
so one thing that the lockdown of the
kovic crisis has also helped us in
is trying and understanding how can we
spend time with
ourselves you know having a solitude
having
enjoying our hobbies reflecting on us
and that's one way
which really we can use to deal with
this chronic loneliness not only in the
pandemic but even after that
really briefly after the pandemic what
happens then will people ditch their dog
or that sex doll
will mental health be such an issue
of course i think this is just the tip
of the iceberg and the beginning
uh we are looking at next six months to
one year uh
mental health issues are going to rise
uh i i
as a mental health professional my
personal take will be that
people will try to at least you know
they will learn to spend more time with
themselves
virtual medium will be a medium of
communication and
uh of course uh things like pets uh
you know as you are mentioning sex dolls
or you know even robotics
they're even virtual robotics artificial
intelligence
these will come up gradually in
mitigating the knowledge
well we'll have to leave it there
thank you very much for being on the
show yeah
thank you now if you've got any
questions on the coronavirus write to us
on our youtube channel
is our science correspondent derek
williams
are there any countries that seem to
have achieved herd immunity
so far
the answer to this is a resounding no um
but it's still worth talking about herd
immunity again at
at this point in the pandemic um just a
reminder
herd immunity is what we all want it's
the tipping point
when enough of the population is immune
to the virus
that an infected person on average
infects
less than one other person so the number
of new infections falls
immunity can come either from having had
the disease
or receiving a vaccine it doesn't matter
which
most estimates say herd immunity will
only be reached with covet 19
when between 60 and 70 percent of the
population
acquires immune status and that could
prove
hard to reach especially if immunity to
source cove two proves to not be
a very long term and those who've had it
or and those who've been vaccinated
which brings me to the country that i
want to talk about from sweden
which last spring swam against the
lockdown
tide by largely leaving society open
there
and it was hit pretty hard by the virus
in return
although reaching herd immunity was
never explicitly
part of its government's coronavirus
strategy it's logical to expect that we
would possibly
see an effect in a place that had such
high
infection rates early on um so are we
seeing one
well interestingly maybe um
despite its looser restrictions the
average daily number of new cases in
sweden remained
quite low throughout the summer even
when they began rising again
in many other european countries with
tighter restrictions
that's not direct evidence that the
beginnings of herd immunity
could be playing a role there but it's a
tantalizing hint
that it might be